what is tough mudder what it is a
challenge that you do with your friends
into that teamwork but camera oddly it's
about having fun you have to do things
like climb over walls roll under barbed
wire run through a field of electric
wires each of which has 10,000 volts in
it anyone that tells you that starting a
business isn't a very scary thing to do
is simply lying to you my harvard
business school professors were very
clear with me will this is a bad idea
i'm not going to pay to run in flames to
claw in the mud we launched in 2010 we
had three events for 20,000 people this
year now up to over 800,000 people
participating but really I feel we're
just getting started one of the things
we saw two years ago was that we weren't
getting the repeater way we wanted
we did some market research and came
back we need to have new obstacles and
then we have to take out some of the old
obstacles some of the things that have
been most successful for us and I have
real fear when I did that one of the new
obstacles that we're very excited about
2014 is Perseus it sends you flying
through a wall of flames of the six feet
tall and the good news bastogne to get
this royal tribal following that number
is growing even quicker than our
participant numbers of knife used to
tell my wife when we were getting going
six months from now I think things will
look calm down
I stop saying that to her now